La clase de hoy se trata de
las partes del alma.
Quiero comenzar con algunos pasajes,
2 de la antigua tradición
literaria griega
y 2 de la cultura de masas
contemporánea,
que demuestran hasta qué punto es
parte del entendimiento
común de la naturaleza
humana que a menudo
estemos en conflicto con
nosotros mismos.
En La República, el libro del que
hemos estado leyendo fragmentos,
Sócrates cuenta una historia
de un hombre tentado
a actuar en contra de su voluntad.
Es la historia de Leoncio y dice así:
"Leoncio, hijo de Aglayón,
subía del Pireo
por la parte exterior del
muro norte de la ciudad
cuando vio unos cadáveres tirados
a los pies del verdugo".
Dice Sócrates, usando la
terminología del apetito de
Platón:
"Sentía el apetito o deseo de verlos.
Pero a la vez le repugnaban y
apartó la mirada.
Durante un rato, luchó contra sí
mismo y se cubrió la cara.
Finalmente, dominado por el apetito,
abrió sus ojos por completo
y corrió hacia los cadáveres diciendo:
'¡Miren ustedes mismos,
malditos desgraciados!
Sáciense con la hermosa vista'".
En esta clase, hablaremos más
de la particular imagen
que Platón tiene en mente sobre el
alma dividida en 3 partes,
incluyendo esta fuerza que
él llama apetito.
Pero la descripción básica que
tenemos aquí no se basa,
de ninguna manera, en ningún marco
Platónico en particular.
La idea de que uno puede, por un lado,
sentirse obligado a hacer algo,
como comer un pastel de
chocolate o ver el Facebook,
son tentaciones que uno puede
intentar controlar
y luchar contra uno mismo.
En las siguientes 4 o 5 clases
veremos con qué tipos de
estrategias contamos,
dado que este tipo de conflictos
surgen inevitablemente.
Ese es nuestro primer
ejemplo de conflicto
de la tradición antigua;
un conflicto entre el impulso
del apetito, por un lado,
y el impulso de cierto tipo de
autorregulación, por el otro.
El segundo ejemplo viene de La
metamorfosis de Ovidio.
Una larga historia de la que
leeremos un pasaje donde Medea,
en contra de su voluntad,
se enamora de un joven llamado Jasón.
Voy a leer una
traducción del siglo
XVII
que está en versos pareados:
"Entretanto, Medea, presa de
un violento deseo,
con su razón lucha por
sofocar el fuego ardiente;
pero lucha en vano.
Algún Dios (dice ella) se resiste,
y la razón desconcertada
hace lo contrario".
Aquí está Medea, presa del deseo,
intentando controlarse mediante la
razón, diciéndose a sí misma
que es absurdo estar
enamorada de este joven,
que es una violación a sus
otras obligaciones.
Pero sus esfuerzos son en vano.
Siente que una fuerza
exterior la controla
y que ignora lo que le dicta la razón.
Esta es una versión en verso del
pasaje que está citado en prosa
en el texto de Jonathan Haidt
que leímos para hoy.
Esta es la continuación
en voz de Medea:
"Pero el amor, el amor
irresistible invade mi alma,
a mi voluntad la persuaden
los sentimientos.
Veo lo correcto y lo apruebo;
condeno lo incorrecto, y aun
así lo persigo".
Este sentimiento de distinguir lo
correcto y estar de acuerdo con ello,
condenar lo incorrecto y no obstante,
descubrir que uno hace aquello que va
en contra del juicio propio,
es un tropo esencial en la
tradición literaria occidental.
Es un tropo esencial en la
tradición filosófica oriental.
Y es un sentimiento sumamente
conocido en nuestras vidas.
El tercer ejemplo de conflicto,
abordado en esta clase
de las partes del alma,
viene del Internet.
Aquí hay un fragmento sobre la
decisión de los clasificados
en el torneo de baloncesto
Sweet 16 del año pasado.
El titular dice: "Las emociones y el
análisis entran en conflicto
al elegir a los ganadores del Sweet 16".
Dice el artículo: "Muchos de los
que apostaron en la NCAA
tuvieron complicaciones la
semana pasada para decidir
si sus corazones los llevaban
por el mal camino".
Haciendo eco de las palabras
de Medea y de Platón,
afirma que es difícil ignorar
los sentimientos durante
"lo que muchos consideran la mejor
final de los deportes".
Y continúa describiendo
lo difícil que es
hacer caso a la razón
y seleccionar un equipo con el que no
se tienen lazos afectivos.
Pero esto no es exclusivo del
contexto deportivo.
Aquí hay un cuarto ejemplo de
un conflicto del alma
según Platón.
Este viene de Oprah, la gran
árbitro de la cultura de masas.
"¡Escuchen!" dice Oprah
en su sitio web,
"¿Por qué es mejor escuchar al
corazón que a la cabeza?".
Quienes hayan hecho la lectura,
-aún no tenemos clickers-
¿piensan que Oprah está de
acuerdo con Platón o con Hume?
¿Está de acuerdo con Platón?
Mano izquierda.
¿O con Hume?
Excelente.
Bien.
Platón piensa que la
razón es la que manda.
Hume sugiere, en el pasaje que leímos,
que la razón es y debería ser
esclava de las pasiones.
Hume no dice precisamente
lo que Oprah está diciendo aquí.
Tendremos oportunidad de hablar más
de esto en las secciones.
Otra vez vemos, igual que en la
historia de Leoncio, en la de Medea,
en la de elegir tu equipo
ganador de baloncesto
y aquí en Oprah, esta idea de
que el alma tiene partes
y que hay conflictos dentro de nosotros.
En esta clase
quiero que revisemos las 5
lecturas para hoy,
3 obligatorias y 2 complementarias,
en las cuales se intenta dar voz,
a través de la
identificación de una
taxonomía,
a esta idea de que a veces somos
arrastrados en una dirección
y a veces en otra.
La primera, que explicaré con
más detalle más adelante,
es la división de Platón entre
razón, espíritu y apetito.
La segunda, es la discusión de
Hume de la relación
entre la razón y la pasión.
Y Jonathan Haidt, en el primer capítulo
del libro que leímos para hoy,
presenta una metáfora estupenda
para entender la relación
entre la razón,
la parte de nosotros mismos sobre la
que tenemos acceso y control
directo y consciente, y por otra parte,
la masa de impulsos e
instintos que nos conforman,
que él sugiere que los
veamos como un elefante
al que buscamos controlar a toda costa.
Lo que sugiere Hume, en el
pasaje que leímos,
es que el impulso y el
ímpetu del movimiento,
para continuar con la metáfora,
viene de la criatura que tiene
los pies en la tierra.
Aunque el jinete puede conducir de
cierta manera al elefante,
el ímpetu para realizar la acción
viene de aquellas partes de
nosotros sobre las que no tenemos
un control racional directo.
La idea de que somos un
manojo de impulsos,
que nos llevan en varias direcciones,
yace en el centro de la imagen tan
influyente, aunque muy polémica,
de la mente humana que Sigmund Freud
presentó en la primera mitad del siglo.
Según Freud, cada uno de
nosotros, cuando nacemos,
somos un manojo de deseos,
necesidades y pasiones incoherentes.
Tenemos el deseo de comer, el deseo de
cierto tipo de comodidades,
un deseo sexual sumamente intenso, etc.
Y esos deseos no tienen un
nivel de consistencia.
Nos arrastran en todas direcciones
y nos hacen actuar de formas que
aspiran a su satisfacción.
La historia del desarrollo
humano, dice Freud,
es la historia del desarrollo de 2
tipos de capacidades reguladoras.
Una, a la que llama ego,
es una parte del yo que es
consciente de la realidad.
Esta parte reconoce que no es
posible querer matar a tu hermano
y casarte con él al mismo tiempo,
porque si tu hermano está muerto,
no puedes casarte con él.
Puede reconocer, de hecho,
que no quieres matar a tu
hermano ni casarte con él,
aunque parte de esa información
podría venir del tercer elemento.
Entonces, tenemos este
manojo de pasiones
que nos arrastran en varias direcciones.
Además, según nos
desarrollamos, aparece una
parte
de nosotros mismos que es
consciente de la realidad.
A medida que eso pasa,
nos hacemos conscientes de
nuestra experiencia.
Mientras estos deseos nos
arrastran en varias direcciones
sin que seamos conscientes de ello,
el ego, el sentido del yo,
es algo sobre lo que tenemos
acceso reflexivo.
A medida que interactuamos
con otros en el mundo,
obtenemos información de formas
apropiadas para regularnos
y actuar según las normas
de la sociedad.
A medida que las interiorizamos
y las aprobamos,
se convierten en lo que
Freud llama superego,
algunas veces considerado
como la consciencia.
La idea es que hay todo tipo
de partes inconscientes de nosotros
mismos, algunas son impulsos
que nos llevan a hacer cosas
como comer y procrear,
algunas son aspectos más
conscientes de las restricciones
de la realidad y algunas son las
normas de la sociedad.
Además de eso, existe una parte más
pequeña de nosotros mismos
de la que somos conscientes.
Hay detalles de la idea freudiana
que han sido desacreditados
por diversas razones.
Pero la idea básica de que los
impulsos inconscientes
nos arrastran en direcciones que
rechazamos se ha convertido
en parte de la autoconcepción de
la cultura occidental.
Es prácticamente imposible
subestimar la influencia
de la idea freudiana en la
literatura, el cine
y el autoentendimiento del siglo XX.
La imagen freudiana,
aunque tiene 3 partes,
no es exactamente la imagen platónica.
El apetito y el ello más o
menos se corresponden,
pero el espíritu no es lo
mismo que el ego,
y la razón y el superego
apenas si se relacionan.
Quienes estén
interesados en este
debate
pueden volver al texto de esta semana y
leer la propia presentación
de Freud sobre su teoría que
acabo de explicar.
La cuarta distinción, que explicaré en
la parte principal de la clase,
es la distinción contemporánea
entre el sistema 1 y el 2,
o entre una especie de sistema de
procesamiento heurístico automático
y un sistema de procesamiento
reflexivo racional.
Lo explicaré en la parte más
importante de la clase.
Ahora quiero presentar nuestro
quinto conjunto de divisiones.
Me refiero a las 4 divisiones
que Jonathan Haidt
plantea en su primer capítulo.
Leímos los textos de Platón,
teníamos la opción de leer
a Hume y a Freud,
y leímos a Evans y a Haidt.
Entonces, la primera distinción de Haidt
es entre la mente y el cuerpo.
Plantea que aunque gran parte de
nuestra regulación corporal
sucede en el cerebro, hay otros lugares
independientes de procesamiento.
En especial, los intestinos,
nuestros órganos digestivos
pueden funcionar relativamente con
independencia del cerebro;
y Haidt da unos ejemplos de esto.
Sorprendentemente, una de las
cosas que no discute
es el famoso ejemplo de Mike,
el gallo sin cabeza.
Aquí está en la portada
de la revista Life.
Este gallo fue decapitado poco
después de la segunda guerra
mundial y llegó a vivir muy
feliz otros 18 meses.
Aquí está bailando.
En YouTube, pueden ver una
versión en vivo de Mike,
el pollo sin cabeza.
Quienes prometieron apagar el Internet,
se están arrepintiendo ahora, ¿verdad?
La cuestión con Mike, el
pollo sin cabeza,
es que existen un montón de
controles motores
que no suceden en el órgano que
esperaríamos, o sea en la cabeza,
sino a lo largo de la columna
vertebral de varias maneras.
La primera división que Haidt advierte
se trata de una
característica biológica
nuestra.
La regulación de la acción sucede
a través de todo tipo de
procesos biológicos,
algunos ubicados acá arriba
y otros que se comunican con partes
de nuestras extremidades
únicamente a través de
zonas inferiores
de la columna vertebral.
La segunda división importante
que Haidt nos recuerda
es la división entre el cerebro
izquierdo y el derecho.
Como muchos de ustedes saben,
el cuerpo calloso recorre todo el
centro de nuestro cerebro
y conecta todo lo que sucede
en el lado derecho
con lo que sucede en el izquierdo.
Resulta que en cierto de tipo de
pacientes con epilepsia,
la única forma de curarlos
de los ataques eléctricos que se
presentan en sus cerebros
consiste en cortar el cuerpo calloso.
Al hacerlo, por motivos médicos
necesarios, la ciencia ha descubierto
el grado en que el procesamiento
realizado en cada lado del cerebro
es relativamente independiente.
Básicamente, todo lo que entra por
el campo de visión derecho
se procesa en el hemisferio izquierdo
y lo todo lo que entra por el
campo de visión izquierdo
se procesa en el hemisferio derecho.
Aunque muchas funciones del cerebro
están duplicadas en los
hemisferios, otras son localizadas.
En concreto, en los cerebros de las
personas diestras el lenguaje
es una actividad del hemisferio
derecho. [corrección: izquierdo].
Haidt describe una famosa
investigación,
realizada en 1950, por el
neurocientífico Michael Gazzaniga,
en la que un paciente que
había sido sujeto
a un corte del cuerpo calloso se
exponía a algunas imágenes
que entraban por el campo
visual izquierdo
y eran procesadas por el
hemisferio derecho del cerebro,
o imágenes que entraban por el
campo visual derecho
y eran procesadas por el
hemisferio izquierdo.
La información procesada
en el lado izquierdo del cerebro,
perdón, en el lado derecho
no está disponible lingüísticamente.
Creo que lo dije mal hace un rato.
El centro del lenguaje está en el lado
izquierdo en la gente diestra.
Cuando se observa algo que
viene del lado izquierdo,
no está disponible lingüísticamente,
no hay un procesamiento
lingüístico de lo que se ve.
Cuando al sujeto se le pide
que explique lo que hay
en su campo de visión, realiza
lo que Gazzaniga llama:
confabulación.
A este sujeto se le han mostrado,
con este lado del cerebro,
un montón de imágenes de nieve y se
le pide que elija algo afín.
Recuerden, es el cerebro derecho,
así que es la mano izquierda.
El sujeto selecciona con
su mano izquierda,
controlada por el cerebro derecho, en
el campo visual izquierdo,
una pala, algo sumamente
útil en la nieve.
Mientras tanto, el hemisferio
izquierdo a través del ojo derecho,
controlando la mano derecha,
ve una pata de pollo
y selecciona un pollo.
Entonces, una parte de su
cerebro ve una pata de pollo
y al elegir algo afín, elige un pollo.
El otro lado de su cerebro ve la nieve
y al elegir algo afín, elige una pala.
Por ahora, todo bien.
Ya expliqué que el cerebro está
segregado de esta manera,
entonces no nos extraña
que el lado derecho
seleccione algo afín a lo que vio
y el izquierdo algo afín a lo que vio.
¿Qué pasa después?
A continuación, el sujeto
mira la pala y el pollo
que ha seleccionado
y se le pregunta por qué ha
elegido esas cosas.
Por lo que respecta al centro
lingüístico del cerebro,
el sujeto no sabe por qué
escogió la pata de pollo.
¿De acuerdo? Esa información no ha
entrado a la parte del cerebro
donde se realiza el
proceso lingüístico.
No obstante, el sujeto hace algo
llamado confabulación.
Dice: "Escogí la pala
porque la necesitaba para
desenterrar la pata de pollo".
Ofrece una explicación
de por qué escogió lo que escogió.
En los casos de hipnosis, sucede
una fenomenología similar.
Los sujetos despertarán en un escenario
con sus brazos y piernas en una
posición determinada
y de inmediato ofrecerán una
explicación confabulada
de los motivos de sus acciones.
Por lo general, somos personas que
leemos nuestro comportamiento
de nuestras experiencias.
Cuando hablemos de la emoción y
del autoentendimiento,
volveremos a abordar este tema.
El tema de los cerebros derecho e
izquierdo tiene 2 aspectos.
Primero, constituye un segundo
ejemplo del argumento biológico
que apoya la idea de que estamos
divididos de ciertas maneras.
En segundo lugar, está la idea
de la confabulación,
para usar la metáfora del
elefante y su jinete,
es como si el jinete
pensara que sus pies
son los que están en el suelo y
no los pies del elefante.
La tercera división que describe Haidt
es la división entre el cerebro
viejo y el cerebro nuevo.
Por un lado, están las
partes del cerebro,
como el tronco cerebral y las
regiones subcorticales,
que compartimos con animales no humanos;
y por otro lado, están las
partes del cerebro humano
más desarrolladas, como la
región cortical
y en particular, el córtex prefrontal.
Haidt cuenta una historia
muy útil para entender cómo
funciona la autorregulación.
Me imagino que muchos habrán visto
estas famosas imágenes de esta persona.
¿Alguien sabe cómo se
llama esta persona?
¿Sí?
Alumno: Phineas Gage.
Catedrática Tamar
Gendler: Phineas Gage.
Es Phineas Gage,
un trabajador de la industria
ferrocarrilera del siglo XIX
que estaba apisonando
dinamita en su trabajo.
La dinamita explotó y esta larga barra
de metal atravesó su cerebro.
Al igual que Mike, el pollo sin
cabeza, Phineas Gage sobrevivió
y de hecho vivió muchos años más.
Al reconstruir el accidente,
se ha descubierto que el
daño que hizo la barra
fue en una zona del cerebro llamada
córtex prefrontal ventromedial.
Aquí está el córtex prefrontal.
El resultado del accidente de Gage
fue como lo que le pasó al profesor
de la Universidad de Virginia
que describe Haidt en su historia.
Hubo una pérdida de capacidad para
cierto tipo de autorregulación.
En cierta forma, igual que Medea,
Gage era capaz de distinguir lo
correcto, lo que debía hacer,
podía entenderlo,
explicarlo y articularlo,
sabía lo que era socialmente adecuado,
pero era incapaz de actuar según lo
que consideraba más apropiado.
Diría algo como: "No deberías gritar
cuando te enojas en un lugar público".
Entendía que ese
comportamiento era
inadecuado,
no obstante era incapaz de
actuar de forma adecuada.
Hacía lo que su ello le
decía, según Freud,
o lo que su apetito le decía,
según Platón.
En varias ocasiones se ha descubierto
que los sujetos con daños en
su córtex prefrontal
tienen dificultades para autorregularse.
Parece que al menos uno de los
lugares donde se asienta
lo que Platón denomina la razón,
es en esta parte del cerebro.
De hecho, existen suficientes pruebas
de que las personas que sufren de
trastorno por déficit de atención
con hiperactividad, TDAH,
tienen menor funcionamiento
del córtex prefrontal que
aquellos que no lo padecen.
Cuando Haidt habla del cerebro viejo,
la parte del cerebro que compartimos
con seres que actúan por
instinto, y del cerebro nuevo,
las partes del córtex que están
especialmente bien desarrolladas
en los seres humanos, como el
córtex prefrontal,
una de las cosas que aborda
es esta capacidad de autorregulación.
Cuando hablemos de la
debilidad de la voluntad,
dentro de 5 clases más o menos,
veremos algunas maneras en las
que podemos explotar
el hecho de tener estos
cerebros complejos capaces
de aprender patrones
mediante ambos sistemas,
el viejo y el nuevo.
Somos capaces de regularnos
al igual que los perros y los gatos.
Si quieres entrenar a tu gata para que
no se siente en el sillón,
decirle: "No te subas al sillón
porque dejas pelos y mi
tía es alérgica",
no es una forma efectiva de entrenarla.
Para entrenarla,
tendrías que poner un trozo
de papel arrugado
que haga un ruido horrible cada
vez que se siente ahí.
O quizás, rociarla suavemente
con una botella de agua
cada vez que se suba.
Así, estableces asociaciones
entre estar en el sillón
y un resultado negativo,
y cambias sus asociaciones al respecto.
Pero no lo haces de forma que implique
una autorregulación reflexiva.
Nosotros, como seres humanos, con
cerebro viejo y nuevo,
podemos regularnos igual
que regulamos y entrenamos
a los animales,
a través de asociar ciertas actividades
con cosas positivas o negativas.
Pero también podemos usar un
tipo de reflexión
y autorregulación que implica
cierto tipo de autocontrol.
Hablaremos más de esto en
clases posteriores.
Ahora quisiera, después de haber
visto algunos textos literarios
en los que articulamos la idea de
que el alma está dividida
y después de haber visto rápidamente
las distintas divisiones que
leímos para hoy...
¡Ay, perdón!
Hay un cuarto ejemplo de Jonathan Haidt.
En realidad,
quiero explicarles el
procesamiento controlado
y el automático, y después
haremos lo que les decía antes.
Algunos de ustedes, cuando
termine esta clase,
saldrán del salón y tal vez
tomarán el elevador
para ir a otro salón del edificio WLH
a la clase de John Bargh.
Quiero explicarles un estudio
que hizo John Bargh,
hace 15 años aproximadamente,
que muestra la relación
entre el procesamiento
controlado y el automático.
Bargh llevó sujetos a su laboratorio
y los hizo participar en una tarea
llamada oración mezclada.
En esta tarea, los sujetos reciben
una lista de 5 palabras, por ejemplo:
él, hermoso, entrada,
relevante y jueves.
Se les pide que hagan una
oración con 4 de ellas.
Al hacerlo, se ven obligados
a poner atención
al significado de las palabras.
La única intención de esta tarea
es hacerlos pensar en varias palabras.
En este estudio, unos sujetos
recibieron un conjunto
con una gran variedad de palabras,
y otros, un conjunto con algunos
términos relacionados
típicamente con los ancianos.
Palabras como arrugado,
bingo, Florida, etc.
Se supone que los sujetos que
tuvieron las oraciones
mezcladas con palabras
asociadas a ancianos
habían primado en sus mentes la
idea de una persona mayor.
La variable dependiente, VD,
que Bargh midió,
era cuánto tardaba la gente,
al salir del estudio,
en caminar al elevador.
Los sujetos que habían
participado en la tarea típica
de oraciones mezcladas caminaban
bastante rápido al elevador.
Pero los que habían recibido
palabras asociadas con los ancianos
se fueron muy lentamente.
De hecho, los sujetos que estaban
en la condición normal
solo tardaron poco más de 7
segundos en llegar al elevador,
mientras que los que
habían sido primados
con palabras relacionadas
con los ancianos
tardaron por lo menos un segundo y
medio más que los otros.
Se supone que esto no se debía
a un pensamiento consciente que dijera:
"Tengo que ir a jugar al bingo".
Se debía a que se había evocado
una imagen determinada
en sus mentes de forma inconsciente,
por debajo del nivel de conciencia, y eso
influyó en su comportamiento.
En una serie de estudios que
Bargh continuó haciendo
en los siguientes años, y hasta ahora,
encontró que este efecto se repetía.
Por ejemplo, algunos
sujetos fueron primados
con términos relacionados
con la cortesía,
otros con términos relacionados
con la mala educación,
y la variable dependiente que medía,
era la probabilidad que tenían de
interrumpir al experimentador
cuando necesitaban preguntarle algo.
Quienes recibieron palabras
asociadas con la cortesía
esperaron casi 15 minutos,
mientras quienes recibieron palabras
asociadas con la mala educación
preguntaban de inmediato e
interrumpían al experimentador.
Más recientemente, en el campo de
la cognición corporizada,
ha estado estudiando cosas como
qué pasa si sostienes una taza
de café caliente o fría
antes de evaluar un currículum.
Los sujetos ayudaban al
experimentador, en el elevador,
a sostener su taza un momento,
y los que sostuvieron la taza
caliente tenían más probabilidad
de evaluar el currículum
de forma positiva
que los que sostuvieron la taza fría.
Es decir, la sensación de
calidez en un campo,
ofrece la sensación de calidez en otro.
Esa es la cuarta división.
Ok. En los últimos 10
minutos de la clase
quiero hablar de los 2
textos pendientes.
Primero,
de la división del alma según Platón
en razón, espíritu y apetito;
y segundo, del texto de
procesamiento doble.
Como la siguiente clase será
explícitamente de procesamiento doble,
si hoy no terminamos de
revisar ese material,
con eso comenzaré la siguiente clase.
El texto algo obsceno de Platón
que les pedí leer para hoy,
espero que sí lo hayan leído,
es muy atrevido y divertido.
Aquí hay una maravillosa
representación del texto
hecha por el filósofo John
Holbo que vive en Singapur.
En el texto, Platón describe las
3 partes del alma humana.
La primera es la que él
llama razón o logos;
representada aquí por el auriga.
La segunda, es el espíritu, a veces
traducido como honor o thumos.
Y la tercera, el apetito o epithumos.
Platón presenta una serie de metáforas
para que comprendamos esto.
En La República,
en el pasaje que leeremos para
la próxima semana,
describe a la razón como un ser
humano, al espíritu como un león
y al apetito como una bestia
con muchas cabezas.
En el pasaje que leímos
para hoy, del Fedro,
Platón describe a la razón
como un "auriga",
al espíritu como "un buen
caballo, de cuerpo noble,
de buena constitución, con un cuello
alto y un porte majestuoso.
Su pelaje es blanco y se controla
con la simple palabra".
Por el contrario, la figura
platónica del apetito es
"una gran mezcla de
extremidades torcidas,
tiene el cuello corto como un
toro, la nariz chata,
la piel oscura y los ojos rojos,
es compañero de la fanfarronería
desenfrenada y de la indecencia,
tiene orejas peludas y es
sordo como un palo,
apenas si obedece al
látigo y a la espuela".
Platón describe en este pasaje,
un acontecimiento bastante fascinante,
en el que un hombre de Atenas se
enamora de un jovencito,
y el caballo oscuro dentro de
él, es decir, su apetito,
está listo para hacer aquellas
actividades que Freud colocaba
en la categoría del ello.
No me refiero a que quisiera salir
a comer con el jovencito.
Mientras tanto, el espíritu
siente la atracción,
pero reconoce que existen
normas sociales
y el auriga intenta mantener
alineados a los caballos.
Sócrates describe cómo el auriga
intenta controlar al caballo oscuro,
mientras el caballo intenta
que el hombre se abrace
con su joven amado.
Dice: "Llega la hora prometida, los
caballos fingen haber olvidado
aquello que el auriga les
pidió olvidar.
El caballo oscuro se los recuerda.
El caballo lucha.
Relincha.
Los empuja.
Los obliga a acercarse
otra vez al joven,
con la misma proposición, y en
cuanto están cerca,
deja caer su cabeza, estira su
cola, muerde el freno
y se avienta sobre el joven
sin vergüenza alguna".
El auriga,
es decir, la razón, la autorregulación,
el superego, el córtex prefrontal,
se siente afligido por los
mismos sentimientos de antes
porque piensa que no debería
participar en esta acción:
"Se siente peor, se repliega igual que lo
haría en el cajón de salida.
Jala el freno con violencia hacia los
dientes del caballo insolente,
con más fuerza esta vez, hace sangrar
su sucia lengua y sus quijadas,
asienta sus patas, lo obliga
firmemente a echarse en el suelo
y lo detiene".
La idea de que una forma de aprender a
controlar nuestras pasiones
es entrenándonos como
entrenaríamos a un animal
salvaje,
mediante la creación de
asociaciones negativas
con cierto tipo de actividades es, de
hecho, una visión básica
de cómo funciona la
autorregulación en el ser
humano.
Con respecto a las pasiones muy fuertes,
en especial con el apetito sexual, es
crucial tener una autorregulación
que actúe como un
antídoto contundente.
Platón considera que en un alma bien
ordenada, la razón, el auriga,
ejerce el control, y el espíritu y el
apetito se doman y entrenan
mediante un proceso de autorregulación.
La República, el libro del que hemos
estado leyendo fragmentos,
describe un proceso mediante el
cual, nuestra parte racional
puede controlar nuestros
espíritus y apetitos.
Platón narra la historia mediante
una metáfora de control,
compara la estructura del alma humana
con la estructura de una ciudad.
Afirma que al igual que en el
alma humana hay razón,
espíritu y apetito, en una
ciudad bien estructurada hay:
guardianes, gobernados por la razón;
tropas auxiliares y soldados,
gobernados por el honor;
y una especie de obrero,
gobernado por el apetito.
Pasando del individuo a la
sociedad y viceversa,
Platón describe una serie de procesos
mediante los cuales las
voluntades, deseos e impulsos
de las tropas auxiliares y
de los obreros,
así como del espíritu y del apetito
pueden entrar en armonía con
aquello que dicta la razón.
Veremos dentro de 3 clases,
que este tipo de armonía
es la respuesta
que ofrece a la pregunta de Glaucón
de por qué es valioso
intrínsecamente actuar de forma
moral.
Así concluyo la presentación del alma
dividida en 3 partes según Platón.
En la siguiente clase
hablaremos del debate de los
informes del procesamiento doble
en el contexto de los 2 textos que
leeremos para la siguiente clase.
El primero, que algunos ya
conocerán o ya habrán visto,
es el discurso de Daniel Kahneman
al aceptar el Premio Nobel.
Pueden escuchar el discurso
o leer un artículo un
poco más detallado
que describe su contenido.
El segundo, es un texto que
escribí sobre el concepto
al que he denominado alief,
que intenta unir algunas de las
ideas que vimos hoy.
Espero verlos el jueves.